اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
كارثه تهدد المدن المنكوبه في سوريا جثه
منسيه تحت الانقاض واوئه على الابواب اما
المساعدات فشحيحه ومتاخره
وفي تركيا
السلطات تقيم الخسائر واداره الكوارث تعلن
تحرك القشره الارضيه اكثر من سبعه امتار
بسبب زلزال
تشريع في الكونجرس الامريكي يحذر من خطر
مسيرات ايران على الاستقرار العالمي ويدعو
لمواجهتها
روسيا تمطر اغلب مدن اوكرانيا بهجمات
صاروخيه من البحر الاسود وتقصف 15 بلده في
باخموت
اهلا بكم لا تزالوا الانظار تتركز على
الدمار الهائل الذي لحقه الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا وايضا على قصص ناجينه والمتضررين
المؤلمه من حول ما عايشوه تحت الانقاض وفي
الوقت ذاته تتركز الامطار على مرحله ما
بعد الفاجعه حيث فصل اخر من المعاناه
والتشريد الامر يحتاج الى تحرك سريع
لمساعده الناجين الذين خسروا بيوتهم
وتوفير ماوى لهم وحمايه المناطق المنكوبه
من اخطار ما بعد الزلزال خوفا من انتشار
الامراض والاوبئه وازاله الانقاذ للبدء في
اعاده الاعمار
[موسيقى]
مخاطر ما بعد الزلزال مشاهدينا كثيره
واكثر ما تهدد الان المناطق المنكوبه في
سوريا والتي تاخر وصول المساعدات ولم تصل
فرق الانقاذ اليها حيث اكد المرصد السوري
ان مئات الجثث لا تزال عالقه تحت الانقاض
ولم تصلها فراق الانقاذ حتى الان وهذا
يرفع حصيله القتلى التي تجاوزت الخمسه
الافواحد وخمسين في سوريا ويرفع ايضا خطر
بقاء الجثث الجثث وانتشار الاوبئه من
جانبها اعربت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
قلقيها الشديد من شح المساعدات في شمال
غرب سوريا عقب وقوع الزلزال المدمر مشيره
الى عدم امكانيه الوصول الى الاشخاص
المتضررين في المناطق السوريه الواقعه تحت
سيطره النظام السوري المنظمه العالميه
اوضحت ايضا مشاهدينا ان النظام الصحي
يعاني الهشاشه الهائله رغم توفر المساعدات
الانسانيه والطبيه الا ان ذلك بالطبع
مستداما اما مراسل العربيه فقد افاد في
سوريا بان فرق البحث والانقاذ انتشلت احدى
عشره جثه جديده في المدن المنكوبه ولم
تعثر على اي احياء خلال الايام الاربعه
الماضيه واضاف المراسل ان المساعدات التي
وصلت عبر المعابر والمطارات الدوليه بدات
بسد جزء مقبول من احتياجات نحو 400 الف
سوري من دون ماوى في مناطق النظام
والمعارضه
ينضم الينا من منبج مراسل العربيه جمعه
عكاش اهلا بك معنا الجمعه بدايه لنبدا
بالمساعدات وحجم هذه المساعدات وهل هي
بالفعل كافيه لسد جزء بسيط من حاجات
المتضررين اثراء هذه الكارثه
نعم يعني حجم المساعدات وتدفقها خلال
ثلاثه ايام الماضيه كان لافت يعني حتى
الان يعني زلزال وحتى الان هناك نحو او
حوالي 600 شاحنه تحمل مساعدات من شتى يعني
الاصناف اغاثيه وانسانيه ومعدات طبيه
وادويه دخلت من جميع المنافذ البريه
لسوريا سوى المنافذ البريه من مع تركيا من
باب السلامه والراعي وباب الهوى او
المنافذ البريه مع دول الجوار من الاردن
ولبنان والعراق اضافه الى 75
طائره تحمل مئات الاطل من المساعدات
الغذائيه اخرها طائره ثالثه سعوديه وصلت
الى مطار حلب
الدوله اضافه الى المعابر الداخليه هناك
حوالي يعني 240 شاحنه وصلت من مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه للاهالي ومن الاداره
الذاتيه 140 منها الى مناطق المعرض شمال
غرب البلاد ومئه شاحنه دخلت امس عبر معبر
التائهه تحمل الوقود الى مناطق النظام
وتحديدا الى مدينه حلب هذه المساعدات
الاماميه الدوليه من دول الدوار المساعده
مساعدات بدات تسد ماذا عن فرق الانقاذ
والمساعده يعني البحث عن احياء انتهت منذ
ايام ولكن ماذا عن انتشار الجثث ما هي
اولويات فرق النقاد المتواجدون في المناطق
المنكوبه
يعني خلال الاربعه ايام ماضيه لم يتم
العثور على اي ناجين جدول تحتها على انقاذ
وبالتالي يعني يبدو ان الاعمال تلاشت
تماما بالعثور على اي ناجين خلال الساعات
الاربعه وعشرين الماضيه تم العثور على احد
عشر جعفر في مناطق النظام وفي مناطق
المعارضه حتى ان اعمال فرق البحث والانقاذ
يعني بدات تسير بوطيره بطيئه جدا وتعتمد
في المرحله الحاليه على البلاغات التي تصل
من الاهالي بمعنى عندما يتم ابلاغ هذه
الفرق بان هناك مفقودين او جثث او شيء ما
تحت مبنى محدده تتوجه هذه الفرق مع
الاليات الى هذه المباني المنهاره بمعنى
انه اليوم او غدا ستنتهي تماما اعمال فرق
الانقاذ والبحث في جميع المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرات النظام والمعارضه وبالتالي ستكون
الاولويات هي فتح فتح طرقات المساعده في
توزيع
المس المناطق المنكوبه ويعني فتح قنوات
الصرف الصحي وانتم بتوصيل المياه وربما
الكهربائي الى المناطق يعني المنكوبه
بالتالي ستتغير الاولويات لربما خلال 24
ساعه المقبله من توقف تام لاعمال البحث
والانقاذ الى امور المساعده والدعم
للمنكوبين وعددهم حوالي 400 الف في جميع
مناطق متضرره في سوريا طيب الجمعه ماذا عن
الاوضاع في ارياف حلب وادلب يعني هل لك ان
تصف لنا كيف حالها
يعني هناك 400 الف شخص
في جميع المناطق المنكوبه الان يتم
التركيز على يعني توزيع المساعدات
الانسانيه العاجله يعني الاغذيه
كالخيام والتنصيب الخيام هناك جهود كبيره
تنزلها فرق الدفاع المدني وحتى المجالس
المحليه في هذه البلدات يعني اعطاء الخيام
والمساعدات للمستحقين لان هناك تزاحم
وفوضى بين الذين تضرروا من الزلزال مباشره
وبين النازحين واعدادهم بعشرات الالاف في
هذه المنطقه على مساله المساعدات الاغاثيه
والانسانيه لان هذا يشكل تحدي بالنسبه
لفرق الانقاذ والمجالس المحليه المختصه في
هذه البلدات يعني يتم محاوله ايواء يعني
ايضا الالاف من الناس الذين حتى الان لم
يصلوا لم يحصلوا على خيم او على مساعدات
عاجله يحاولون بكل الط رق الممكنه يعني
ايصال المساعدات للجميع الاسماء وان حجم
المساعدات التي دخلت من جميع المغابر
البريه وايضا المطارات بدات تسود يعني في
المرحله الاولى جزءا مقبولا من احتياجات
هؤلاء المتضررين وهناك توقعات لوصول
المزيد من المساعدات كذلك شكرا لك من منبج
مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش
اشار مراسلنا جمعه عكاش قبل قليل مشاهدينا
بانها وصلت ثالث طائرات الاغاثه السعوديه
الى مطر حلب الدولي والتي تحمل على متنها
مساعدات عاجله لضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
منها مواد غذائيه ايوائيه وطبيبيه متنوعه
الطائره الاغافيه السعوديه التي اعلنها
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه جاءت ضمن سلسله من الطائرات
لمساعده المتضررين في كل من سوريا وتركيا
بشكل عاجل اما حول الاوضاع او الوضع
الكارثي في سوريا اكدت الشبكه السوريه
لحقوق الانسان ان تاخر وصول المساعدات
الامميه لمتضرري زلزال شمال غرب سوريا
تسبب في زياده عضه الضحايا مطالبه بضروره
ارسال فرق تقييم الكوارث في اسرع وقت
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه وذكرت الشبكه
الحقوقيه في تقرير ان استجابه الامم
المتحده لم تكن بالشكل الذي يتناسب مع هول
الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا حيث تركت
المنظمات الم دنيه المحليه تواجه بمفردها
اهوال الزلازل ومخلفاته معنى من ريف ادلب
الصحفي محمد الاشقر اهلا بك معنا محمد هل
لك ان تنقل لنا الصوره في ريف ادلب الان
وحيث ان تحديدا ربما انت في معبر باب
السلامه
نعم نعم يعني في الحقيقه اوضاع كارثيه
يعانيها المتضررون الناجون من هذا الزلزال
خصوصا ان المطلب
التامين الماوى لهؤلاء المتضررين والذين
يقدرون بالالاف يعني الى حد هذه اللحظه
نسبه كبيره منهم يقطنون مراكز
المؤقته طبعا نعم نحن الان في معبر باب
السلامه الحدودي مع تركيا في ريف حلب
الشمالي طبعا المساعدات الامميه التي دخلت
من هذا المعبر حتى هذه اللحظه هي 13 شاحنه
محمله بالمساعدات الاغاثيه الغذائيه
والغير غذائيه طبعا بحسب المكتب الاعلامي
لمعبر باب السلامه فان الظهر اليوم سيشهد
دخول قافلتين جديدتين محملتين بالمساعدات
الامميه طبعا حركه المعبر هنا بشكل عام هي
هي تشمل شاحنات محمله بالمساعدات
الانسانيه لعده
ومنظمات انسانيه وجمعيات خيريه بالاضافه
لشاحنات محمله بالمساعدات العينيه التي تم
جمعها من خلال حملات التبرع الشعبيه التي
اطلقت
بالخارج ان سمحت لي ان اتحدث قليلا عن
احصائيات معبر باب الهوى وطبعا الى يوم
امس سجل دخول
محمله بالمساعدات الامميه وبحسب مدير
العلاقات العامه والاعلاميه في معبر باب
الهوى فان
ظهر اليوم سيشهد دخول 22 قافله جديده
محمله بالمساعدات الامميه تحمل مواد
اغاثيه غذائيه وغير غذائيه ستدخل الاراضي
السوريه عبر معبر باب الهوى طبعا بحسب ما
تحدث له لنا العميد قاسم القاسم مدير معبر
باب السلامه هنا قال ان هناك اتفاق مبدئي
على السماح بالدخول المساعدات الامميه من
معبر باب السلامه حيث اقف هنا لمده ثلاثه
اشهر طبعا معبر باب السلامه له اهميه
جغرافيه يعني لايصال المساعدات للمتضررين
يعني هناك العديد من المناطق القريبه من
معبر باب السلامه مناطق تضررت
من هذا الزلزال المدمر العديد من
الناجين المتضررين الذين لجاوا الى مدن
وبلدات يعني قريبه من معبر باب السلامه
الصحفي محمد الاشقر
زحفا على بطنه وسط الركام والجدران
المهدمه التي تحاصره من كل مكان خرج
اللاجئ السوري من بين انقاض بنايته التي
دمرها الزلزال بعد ان ازاح بيديه كتله
اسمنتيه فتحت له طريقا الى النافذه التي
تسرب منها ضوء وهواء ساعده على انقاذ
طفليه وزوجته مراسل العربيه في غازي عنتاب
زيدان زنكلو معه التفاصيل
خرج محمود اللاجئ السوري الى الحياه مجددا
مع زوجته واطفاله الثلاثه بعد فتره زمنيه
قضوها تحت انقاض بيتهم الذي انهار من شده
الزلزال في مدينه اصلاحيه بغاز عنتاب
جنوبي تركيا طلعت
صغيره حطته بحضنه وانا حطيت اولادي هدول
الاثنين وسام وسيم حطيتهم
وحطيت راس مرتي هيك وبست راسي على الارض
ونزل السقف علينا ورجعت صارت تصير هز كمان
يعني تحت الارض ضلينا فتره يعني الفتره
والله ايش قد بالضبط يعني ما بعرف قديش
اجاني صوت من برا يعني صوت اتراك اني عم
يقولوا تمام تمام يعني
على البيت وسط دائره الخوف ورائحه موت
منبعثه من الجوار بات لزاما على محمود ان
يمسك بخطوط الحياه المتبقيه ويحاول
النجاه او صرت اضرب يمين ويسارة مد ايدي
يعني بدي انقص حالي انقذ الاولاد يطلع لي
حيطان وين ما اضرب ايدي يطلع لحيطان يعني
بعدين طلع لي صخره كبيره حجره ما بعرف شو
صرت تهزه واخذه وجيبها وهيك اخذه وجيبها
وتفشتها نزلت وين بالارض بالغرفه الثانيه
وين نزلت والله ما بعرف وفتح الطريق شوي
طريق فتح لكنه غير كاف للخروج من قعر
الركام الذي كاد ان يتحول لقبر لولا اراده
الحياه وانا ومنبطح يعني لا فوقي يعني ما
في عشره سنتي فوق راسي يعني حيط سقف
وعم بسحفه وبطلع صرت افتح طريق وشيل بلوك
وما بعرف ايش اغراض وكركبي وقزيز طريق هون
طبعا كلياته انا بطني يعني
طلعت هيك شفت اجاني مثل اجاني هواء يعني
شميت هوا شميت هاي مثل اذا شفت السماء مثل
الحلم ضو ما بعرف يعني ما بتذكر بالضبط
ايش بس قلت ان شاء الله فرجت
عزل الحجر وبلوك وشيل قدامي وامشي
اطلعت هيك لقيت الشباك لقيت الشباك مكسور
كله مطعوج اذا نافذه وحيده للحياه ستنقل
هذه العائله من ضفه الموت الى ضفه اخرى
وشفت السيخ سيخ الشباك مطعوج كماجته طلعت
الحمد لله رب العالمين طلع مكسور من طرف
واحد
صوره الويو بايدي طبعا انا متشطح يعني
بس ينكسر معي ما انكسر بس الا والحمد لله
وطلعت فاتحه يعني هيك فاتحه هيك يعني
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني شيء خلصت
هذه العائله فرصه جديده لكنها لم تعطي
عوائل اخرى تلك الفرصه الموت تلقفهم تحت
اطنان من الركام والالم
وصرخات الانين زيدان زنجلو العربيه من
مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب
اطلقت مشاهدينا منظمه الصحه العالميه
تحضيرات من اخطار ما بعد الزلزال التي
تهدد حياه مئات الالاف وذلك بعد تضرر
شبكات المياه والصرف الصحي ودرجات الحراره
المنخفضه وانتشار الامراض والاوبئه فيما
توقع مسؤولون صحيون اتراك مزيدا من
التدهور وتفشي اوبئه كالحصبه والالتهاب
الرئويين واعلن رئيس فرع الصحه العامه
ان التدابير الحاليه المتخذه ليست كافيه
لتفادي خطوره الوضع الصحي وذلك بعد تعطيل
خدمات التطعيم خاصه عند الاطفال دون سن
الخامسه بالاضافه الى سوء التغذيه وحضرت
تقارير من استمرار انعدام الامن واماكن
المعيشه وظروف الطقس في الولايات المتضرره
من الزلزال وعلى اثر هذه المخاطر سيما مع
تلاشى عمليات البحث عن ناجين وبدا عمليات
رفع الانقاذ حيث عدد كبير من الموتى
والمفقودين اصبحت فرق الانقاذ فيها طيب
بتركيا ترتدي ملابس العزل وذلك خشيه من
انتشار الامراض والاوب التي تحدثنا عنها
للتو التفاصيل في تقرير مفيدنا الى عطاي
عمار هندي
في اليوم العاشر على الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا بدات تختفي عمليات البحث عن
الناجين تحت الانقاض العمليات هنا تتركز
على انتشال الجثث الموتى والمفقودين وفرق
الانقاذ بدات تاخذ شكلا ولونا جديدا ترتدي
ملابس العزل خشيه الامراض والاوبئه
وانتشارها خصوصا مع وجود اعداد كبيره من
الجثامين التي لا تزال تحت انقاض البنايات
المدمره في انطاكيا في هاتاي واسر تبحث
عمن لديها من المفقودين والذين لم يعرف
مصيرهم حتى اللحظه
عمار الهندي انطاكيا
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
القطارات الحدائق والملاعب تتحول الى
ملاجئ للمنكوبينه جراء الزلزال
احييكم من جديد اعدت وزاره التخطيط
التركيه تقريرا مشاهدينا يكشف حجم الخسائر
التي منيت بها البلاد ويشدد على ضروره هدم
المباني المعرضه للخطر بشكل فوري وعاجل
حيث اهلكت الزلزال المزدوج اكثر من نصف
مباني عشر محافظات وتضم هذه المباني
مليونا وثمانمائه الف منزل او مكتب في
جنوب شرق تركيا ووفقا التقرير فان نحو 50
الف مبنى لم تعد صالحه فهي اما تدمرت كليا
او ايهلت للسقوط كما وتعرض نحو 11 الف
مبنى لاضرار متوسطه وتسعه وتسعين الفا
لضرر طفيف فيما نجى 180 الف مبنى من الضرر
بحسب نحو اكثر من 7000 خبير حققوا بما
لحقوا من اضرار في 387 الف مبنى
واكد التقرير كذلك انه لم يتم تنظيف اي
انقاض قبل استخراج عينات منها لمعرفه جوده
الخرسانه او الهيكل وعليه اعلن وزير
البيئه والتخطيط العمراني التركي ان اعمال
اعاده الاعمار في المناطق المنكوبه ستبدا
نهايه الشهر الحالي بعد استكمال تقييم
الاضرار خلال اسبوع
[موسيقى]
عمده اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو حذر من خطر
انهيار نحو 90 الف مبنى اذا ضرب زلزال اخر
مدينه اسطنبول اغلى اوضح ايضا ان المباني
المعرضه لخطر الانهيار في اي زلزال يبلغ
ضعف ما كانت تعتقده الاداره السابقه داعيا
للتحرك السريع لتحسين الهياكل والمباني
بما يتماشى مع قوانين البناء في المناطق
المعرضه للزلزال طبعا واشار ايضا الى صدور
العفو عن نحو 317 الف مبنى مخالف خلال
الفتره الماضيه وفي السياق شهدت بالامس
تركيا حمله اعتقالات جديده طالت مقاول احد
المباني المدمره في قهرمان مرعش حيث جرى
اعتقاله في منطقه بودروم يذكر ان السلطات
التركيه شنت مؤخرا اعتقالات للمقاولين
والرجال الاعمال وذلك بسبب عيوب ومخالفات
في المباني المنهاره جراء الزلزال اذا
الزلزال في تركيا هدى اركان الكثير فوق
سطح الارض حتى في اعماقها احدث تغييرا
هائلا في نصائح
التكنونيه حيث اعلنت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه افاد ان القشره الارضيه
تحركت بمقدار
7.3 امتار وذلك بفعل زلزال قهرمان ومرعش
جاء ذلك على لسان مدير الحد من مخاطر
الزلازل اورهان الذي قال ان قشره الارض
اهتزت بشده لمده دقيقتين اثناء الزلزال
ويتراوح عمقها ما بين ثمانيه ونصف وعشره
كيلومترات تحت الارض مبينا ان تركيا تواجه
وضعا غير عادي خاصه وان الهزات الارتداديه
بلغ عددها اكثر من 3800 واشار الى ان عدد
الهزات الارتداديه التي ترى وحت قوتها ما
بين ثلاثه واربعه درجات على مقياس ريختر
بلغ
1283 في حين ان التي كانت بين اربعه وخمسه
درجات بلغت
394 كما وتم تسجيل 38 هز ارتداديه بقوه 5
الى 6 درجات على مقياس الخطر معنا من عمان
صخر النسور مختص في علوم الارض
والجيولوجيا نقيب الجيولوجيين الاردنيين
واتحاد الجيولوجيين العرب اهلا بك معنا في
هذه النشره بدايه لنفهم منك ما تاثير تحرك
قشره الارض خصوصا وان التقارير تشير الى
انها بالفعل تحركت سبعه فاصله ثلاثه امتار
بفعل الزلزال في قهرمان مرعش
شكرا لكم واسعد الله صباحكم للتنويه انا
كنت سابقا نقيبا للجيولوجيين الحقيقه ما
حدث يعني امر جلل وما حدث في تركيا خلال
سبعين سنه بجوز نحتاج في منطقتنا العربيه
لالف او اكثر عام حتى يحدث من زلازل مدمره
هذه الزلازل نتيجه حركه الصفائح المحاطه
فيها تركيا الصفيحه العربيه والصفيحه
والافريقيه كلها تضغط باتجاه الصفيحه
الامازوليه وهي معظم اجزاء تركيا موجوده
عليها وهي شبه ثابته وصغيره وبالتالي كل
هذا الضغط عبر السنوات ولد هذه الطاقه مما
ادى الى ما حدث من من حركات تكتونيه معقده
ولا زالت وستستمر
نتائجها في الهزات الارتداديه وهذا التشوه
الذي حصل لابد يكون هنالك اعاده توازن
الطبيعه لا تقبل الفراغ سيكون هنالك
التوازن هذه باي شكل سيكون سيد صخر يعني
هل ربما سنرى مزيد من الزلازل ربما في
مناطق ليست منطقه مناطق زلازل يعني
يعني اليوم شاهدنا مثلا في الفلبين
واحد وهذا معروف اليوم لانه الفلبين تقع
ضمن حلقه نار حزام ناري
معتاده معظم 80% من زلازل موجوده في هذه
المناطق سيكون هنالك التعبير عن طريق
الهزات للارتداديه بتفاوت قرب المناطق
وحسب طبيعه كل
صفيحه
ونقاط ضعف الخواصر الضعيفه التي يسميها
اللي هي صدوها التي تحيط به كل هذه
الصفائح وبالتالي حتى نحقق هذا التوازن
سيستمر مزيد من الهزات الارتداديه ولكن
بحده
وشده اذا انتبهت لحضرتك اثناء تقريركيه
هنالك تناقص في ست درجات وصلنا الى الخمسه
ولكن نتحدث عن هزات تتسبب بها هذه الهزه
كما شاهدنا في عام 1939 سيد صخر يعني في
زلزال الدرنجان في تركيا عندما ضرب بقوه
7.9 او حتى 8 درجات وتسبب وقوع اربعه
زلازل في سنوات اخرى كانت في عام 1900
اعتقد 49 يعني كان هناك هزه لها علاقه في
تلك الهزه السابقه في عام 39
نعم هلا تفسير موضوع تحرير الطاقه
المختزنه
كبير من المشهد
بامانه وهذا نتيجه غياب التنسيق في
المنطقه لان
صلحت سابقا بان الكوارث الطبيعيه عابره
للحدود يوم لو كان مركز اقليمي بيدرس
المنطقه ككل كان استطعنا ان نذهب الى عمل
مؤسسي بعيدا الفتاوى الفرديه والاجتهادات
الفرديه وهذا يعني امر اقلق الناس كثيرا
في بعض مناطقنا ايضا العربيه
كنت نقول بانه ما حدث حتى في ازمير ب 99
وقبل ذلك في ال 41 و 39 وال 43 في تركيا
منطقه معتاده حتى ان زلزال بحجم اربعه ونص
لا يقلق ولا ولا يشعر فيه ولا يتحدث فيه
كباقي المناطق العربيه ما حدث في نابلس
وفي عندنا في عمان بالامس زلزال ثلاث
درجات لا يشعر في
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
في تركيا اصبح الامر غير مستبعد يعني
نتحدث عن مناطق واسعه تاثرت
بالزلزالين ودعينه ويذكر بان زلزال الفجر
6 شباط كان سبعه فاصله ثمانيه وبعد العصر
في نفس اليوم كان 7.5 وبالتالي الان معظم
المناطق التركيه هي عرضه
الزلازلات الارتجاجيه والجوار لها قد يمتد
شاهدنا في لبنان
هزات في قبرص حسن الهزات ولكن
معدل اقل بالتالي يعني يستمر هذه الهازات
وتستمر هذه الحركه
التوازنيه للقشره الارضيه
ربما اسابيع واشهر قادمه حتى يعود توازن
من قشر الارضي ولكن ان تتخيل بحجم
التغييرات اللي فعلا حلمه بالمستقبل بحاجه
انه سلط الضوء عليه ما حدث في باطل الارض
من عمليات معقده حول
اماكن تواجد النفط والغاز
هل لك ان تبسط لنا تاثير تحرك القشره
الارضيه على البشر
يعني انا سمعت التقرير بانه في ازاحه معدل
سبعه متر على الواقع لمشاهد كيف هذا هل
اذا كان تصادم سيتشكل يعني اذا كانت
الحركه التصادميه
تشكلتنا جديده ام سيكون هنالك حفر من
انهداميه نتيجه اذا كانت الصدى تباعدي
وبالتالي هو تاثيره على الحركه التكتونيه
وعلى مستوى الزلازل مستقبلا لانه هذه
الصفائح في حركه دائمه الصفيحه العربيه
تتجه باتجاه الشمال وتحتك في الصفيحه
الاماميه
اخريتين وبالتالي هذه الحركه الدائمه
للصفيحه العربيه باتجاه الصفيحه
الارادولاك وبتولد طاقه يتم التعبير عنها
في تفريغها جزء من هذه الطاقه من خلال
الهزات الارضيه بالتالي هذه الحركه
والازاحه ستؤثر
واعتقد وهذا من باب الاجتهاد وليست الفتوى
ثابته على مستوى الزلازل في
[موسيقى]
المستقبلات على حدوث اي تسونامي سيد صخر
لا زالت الاشارات بعيده جدا يعني عن موضوع
السلابي لانه معظم هذه على اليابس هو
بعيده عن المناطق المحيطات والبحار وبال
مستوى حتى دول الجوار في التحذير من
تسونامي خفضت مستوى التحذير في موضوع
تسونامي شكرا لك من عمان صخر النسور مختص
في علوم الارض والجيولوجيا
ضمن مراحل ايواء المنكوبين واعاده الاعمار
قصصت السلطات التركيه فضاءات مفتوحه لنص
بالخيام ملعب كره قدم بقهرمان مرعش تحول
الى مخيم للمتضررين نتابع
اصوات المشجعين الى انين فاقدين وفزع
مفجوعين طابور من الجائعين المتلهفين
لمعرفه مصيرهم احتضنت الخيام الجميع
باستثناء محمد واولاده
سيبيتون بالعراء اليوم بسبب نقص الخيام ما
حصلنا خيمه لانه الزلزال ضرب 10 ولايات
عشر ولايات يعني عدد ليس بالقليل في
الولايه بتطلع مليونين نسمه مليون نسمه
يعني اكبر دوله ما بتستطيع تغطي بين
مساعدات الانقاذ او المساعدات الانسانيه
والحمد لله يعني الحكومه التركيه ما قصرت
يلهو الاطفال على امل ان ينسوا ازمه ستؤثر
عليهم مستقبلا كما يقول مختصون احمد اخرج
قريبه وزوجته من تحت الانقاض لم يلحق على
ابنهما الذي فارق الحياه يعيش في هذه
الخيمه ثلاثه عشر فردا من عائلته والله
نحن كنا نايمين انا ومرتين حسينا بزنزال
يعني بس احنا فكرنا بنومنا يعني بنام
بدا الزلزال هنا زلزل البشر والحجر قبل ان
يتركهم في العراء خارج منازلهم يسكنون
الخيامه ويتلقون المساعدات من جهات محليه
ودوليه
لاجل غير معلوم عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
قهرمان مرعش
[موسيقى]
من زلزال تركيا وسوريا الى الولايات
المتحده والمسيرات الايرانيه طرح اعضاء من
الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري تشريعا في
مجلس الشيوخ ينددوه بالمسيرات الايرانيه
ويطالب بالتصدي لها وحمايه المدنيين في
الشرق الاوسط من مخاطرها ونص التشريع على
ان المسيرات الايرانيه ادت بالفعل الى
تفاقم التهديدات ضد الاستقرار العالمي
وتسببت بالفوضى في الشرق الاوسط واشار الى
ضروره توجه اداره بايدن الى خلق حلول
مبتكره بالتعاون مع الشركاء للتصدي
للمسيرات الايرانيه وردع النظام وكلائه
اما السيناتور الديمقراطيه بوب فقال ان
التشريع المؤيد من الحزبين او المؤيد يعزز
التزام واشنطن بمواجهه التهديدات التي
يشكلها تطوير ايران للانظمه الجويه غير
الماهوله خاصه بعد بيعها لروسيا
واستخدامها في اوكرانيا
كارثه تهدد المدن المنكوبه في سوريا جثه
منسيه تحت الانقاض واوبئه على الابواب
والمساعدات شحيحه ومتاخره
وفي تركيا السلطات تقيم الخسائر واداره
الكوارث تعلن تحرك القشره الارضيه اكثر من
سبعه امتار بسبب الزلزال
تشريع في الكونغرس الامريكي يحذر من خطر
مسيرات ايران على الاستقرار العالمي ويدعو
لمواجهتها
روسيا تمطر اغلب مدن اوكرانيا بهجمات
صاروخيه من البحر الاسود وتقصف 15 بلده في
بخموت
احييكم من جديد جنه القوات الروسيه ضربات
صاروخيه مشاهدينا عديده على مناطق
اوكرانيه منها برسكو فيسكا او باسكو بيكا
وباخوت وغيرها وذلك بعدما تعهد الدول
الغربيه بزياده المساعدات العسكريه
ومن الجانب الاوكراني اعلن مسؤولون عن
تصدي الدفاعات الجويه لخمسه صواريخ روسيه
اطلقت من البحر الاسود اوضاع وصفها الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير بالصعبه للغايه رغم
تصدي قوات بلاده للضربات الروسيه في
موازاه ذلك تتصاعد وتطورات المعركه الاشد
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه معركه بخموت
حيث اعلنت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
الاوكرانيه عن تلقي خمسه عشره بلده في
باخموت هجمات صاروخيه وقصفا روسيا مدفعيا
وبريا كما دمر الجيش الروسي مبنى سكانيا
من مما اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص في منطقه
بوكوسك وحاول ايضا التقدم في منطقتي
وبيتني
وفق القيادي الاوكرانيه السابق
الذي وصف الاوضاع في دنيتك بشديده الصعوبه
ومن هناك ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا تقدم ملحوظ
للقوات الروسيه وتقارير اوروبيه تتحدث عن
ان الجانب الاوكراني يستنفذ الذخيره اسرع
مما يمكن توفيرها
نعم فاطمه صباح الخير بالفعل القوات
الروسيه تتقدم في محور مقاطعه في جميع
النواحي الناحيه الجنوبيه من المقاطعه حيث
مدينه غلادار والناحيه الشماليه حيث مدينه
باخموت بالفعل ما زالت قوات فاجنر تطوق
مدينه اباخموت من النواحي الثلاثه
الجنوبيه والشماليه والشرقيه وتدور اسخن
المعارك في المناطق الجنوبيه والشرقيه حيث
معامل التعليب اللحوم ومسالك اللحوم كما
ان المنطقه الشماليه شهدت بعد السيطره على
بلده اوغلادار التقدم الى بلده اخرى
ذكرتها فاطمه وهي باراس كويوفسكا تلك
البلده اكمل الطوق عليها الجيش الروسي او
قوات فاجنر تحديدا
واصبحت محاصره الحديث عن 1500 جندي
اوكراني محاصر في هذه المدينه وتسيطر قوات
فاجنر على هضبات مرتفعه من الناحيه
الشرقيه من هذه البلده هذه البلده اصلا هي
في شمال باخموت الحديث عن قصف مستمر من
هذه المرتفعات على الجنود المحصنين داخل
هذه البلده
والحديث ايضا من المصادر من ارض المعارك
هناك في باقمت بان هذه المجموعات المقاتله
لديها كميه كبيره من الاسلحه داخل البلده
وذلك ما سيجعلها تقاوم لفتره اطول اي ان
هذا الحصار ربما يستمر لايام او لاسابيع
لكن ما لابد ما لابد ان نشير اليه هو
انخفاض وتيره القصف الاوكراني على مقاطعه
دانيس خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وخلال
الايام الماضيه بالعموم 75 قذيفه وصاروخ
سقطت على انحاء المقاطعه خلفت اصابتين
واضرار في عدد من المباني طبعا يرجى
المراقبون هذا الانخفاض بتقدم روسيا في
هذه المحاور الجنوبيه والشماليه وحتى في
الوسط كما انهم يؤكدون ان قصف القوات
الروسيه المستودعات الذخيره ولمنصات
الصواريخ ومدافع هاوزر كما تعلن الدفاع
الروسيه هو سبب هذا الانخفاض والسبب الاخر
هو دفع القوات الاوكرانيه للابتعاد اكثر
عن العاصمه دانيت شكرا لك من دونيت مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر
السفاره الروسيه لدى الامم المتحده قالت
ان على واشنطن محاوله اثبات انها ليست
وراء تخريب خطي انابيب نور ستريم واحد
واثنين لنقل الغاز من روسيا الى غرب
اوروبا وفي بعين لها اعتبرت السفاره
الروسيه ان تخريب خطين نورس واحد واثنين
ارهابا دوريا وياتي ذلك بعدما زعم الصحفي
الاستقصائي سيمور هرش بان خطوط انابيب
دمرت في سبتمبر من العام الماضي من قبل
الولايات المتحده وذلك في عمليه سريه فيما
نفى البيت الابيض هذه المزاعم واصفني
اياها بالكاذبه
قال مسؤولون في الحزب الحاكم في اليابان
ان المناطيل الصينيه ستكون سببا لاقامه
علاقات وتبادل معلومات مع تايوان وياتي
ذلك بعدما اعلنت الدفاع اليابانيه في بيان
انها تفترض بقوه ان مناطير استطلاع مسيره
واجساما طائره صينيه رصيدت في السابق في
مجالها الجوي
مصادر مطلعه مشاهدينا افادت لشبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه بان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي اجرى عمليتي بحث جديدتين في
جامعات
تتعلقان بالتحقيق في تعامل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع الوثائق السريه فيما
فتش عملاء مكتبه تحقيقات منزل بايدن
بولايه ديلور مطلع الشهر الجاري وفقا
لتاكيدات محامي الرئيس
واوضحت مصادر مطلعه ان عمليات البحث التي
لم يكشف عنها من قبل اجريت في الاسابيع
الاخيره وبموافقه وتعاون الفريق القانوني
للرئيس اما السلطات النيوزلنديه في
نيوزلندا اعلنت ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا اعصار
نيوزيلندا الى خمسه قتله فيما تم اجراء
اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من منازلهم بسبب
الفيضانات التي خلفها الاعصار
وحذرت السلطات سكان المناطق الشرقيه
المتضرره من مرور الاعصار من ان مزيدا من
الامطار الغزيره ستهطل في الساعات المقبله
وفي خبر يهم تغير المناخي حذرت دراسه
اجرتها مجموعه بحث علميه في جامعه
كانتربري في نيوزيلندا من ان ذوبان الكتل
الجليديه يعرض حياه الملايين من البشر الى
الخطر حيث يعيش 15 مليون شخص في جميع
انحاء العالم تحت تهديد الفيضانات
المفاجئه والمميته نصفها في الهند
وباكستان
ووفق الدراسه فان الذوبان التدريجي لتلك
الانهار والبحيرات الجليديه وتاكل التربه
يرفعان خطر اقتحام البحيره الجليديه التي
من الممكن ان تؤدي الى دمار كبير ويامل
معد البحث ان تساعد دراستهم الحكومات
والمنظمات الدوليه للبدء بالفعل في
استخدام الوسائل للدفاع عن تلك المجتمعات
لاسيما الواقعه في اتجاه مجرى الانهار مما
يشمل اخلاء ووضع اجهزه للتحذير المسبق
للفيضانات
الى الرياض العاصمه السعوديه التي بدات
فيها عمليه فصل التوام السيامي اليمني
سلمان وعبد الله وعمرهما اربعه اشهر وذلك
في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال
في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه وتستغرق
العمليه التي يعمل عليها 35 طبيبا وكادرا
فنيا وطبيا تستغرق عشره ساعات او عشر
ساعات على 70 مراحل معنى من الرياض مراسل
العربيه نواف عزيز اهلا بك معنا نواف اذا
في اي مرحله وصلت العمليه الان
نعم مراحل متقدمه وصل اليها الفريق الطبي
السعودي العامل على عمليه فصل التوام
السيامي اليمني عبد الله وسلمان الان تم
كما نشاهد تمت عمليه الفصل قبل دقائق فقط
اعلن الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه الجراح
الشهير الذي يقود الفريق الطبي السعودي
العامل على عمليه الفصل بانه تم فصل
التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد الله
والان كما نشاهد وصلنا الى مرحله متقدمه
اذا كنا نستطيع رؤيه الدكتور عبد الله
الربيعه بعد عمليه الفصل بان الان كما ذكر
لنا قبل قليل الدكتور عبد الله بان
المرحله ما بعد فصل التوام السيامي اليمني
سلمان وعبد الله لا تقل اهميه وصعوبه عن
المراحل الاولى ومراحل العمل على الفصل
كونه التوام السيامي سلمان وعبد الله
تعتبر العمليه
عمليه فصلهم معقده جدا
يعني الطفلين المسالك البوليه
نعم كما ذكرتهم
الاتصال لدى التوام بمنطقه البطن والحوض
والمسالك البوليه بالاضافه الى بعض
الاجزاء الاخرى الحساسه عمليه الفصل تمت
فعلا الفريق الطبي قبل دقائق فقط اعلن
الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه بالنجاح عمليه
الفصل
واكد بان المراحل القادمه لا تقل اهميه عن
مرحله فصل التوام السيامي اليمني عبد الله
وسلمان كونها تعتبر مرحله اخرى مرحله من
الترميم والاجراءات الطبيه الاخرى ضمن
العمليه لكن نحن نلاحظ ارتياح كبير لدى
الفريق الطبي السعودي حقيقه 35
طبيب
واخصائي وفني نلاحظ ارتياح لديهم كبير
وهذا ربما عاده يعبر عن
التفاؤل والتوقع بنجاح العمليه بنسبه
كامله لا تزال العمليه مستمره تستغرق ربما
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات الى اربع ساعات نحن
الان في مرحله تعتبر حساسه قبل قليل كنا
نتواجد داخل غرفه العمليات ولكن تم
اخراجنا قبل قليل لان هذه المرحله تعتبر
حساسه ولا يجب ان يتواجد داخل غرفه
العمليات الا الفريق الطبي المخصص لعمليه
فصل التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد
الله لازلنا ننتظر المراحل القادمه وسنكون
متابعين للمراحل الاخرى كما هو مخطط له
لدى المتابعه كل خطوه بخطوه معك نواف
نتمنى لهم الشفاء العاجل شكرا لك
انتشرت فرق الانقاذ جثه طفله من تحت
الانقاض لكن لم يتم التعرف على هويتها
لتعد بعد ذلك من مجهول الهويه
اعداد كبيره من الاطفال تحت الركام لا
تزال مفقوده ومنها ما يتم اخراجه كما حدث
للتو في هاتاي في انطاكيا من تحت انقاض
هذا المنزل فرق الانقاذ هذه التي ترتدي
العزل ملابس العزل اخرج الطفله عمرها شهر
في هذا الكيس الاسود واستدعي كل من يقف
هنا للتعرف اليها فتحوا الكيس لكن احدا لم
يتعرف اليها بعد وبالتالي ستنتظر هذه
الطفله في هذا الكيس الاسود حتى ياتي
الشخص الذي يتعرف اليها والا ستعد
من مجهولي الهويه
عمار الهندي انطاكيا
[موسيقى]
في الختام دوما نذكر بابرز العناوين
كارثه تهدد المدن المنكوبه في سوريا جثه
منسيه تحت الانقاض واوبئه على الابواب اما
المساعدات فهي شحيحه ومتاخره
في تركيا السلطات تقيم الخسائر واداره
الكوارث تعلن تحرك القشره الارضيه اكثر من
سبعه امتار بسبب الزلزال
تشريع في الكونغرس الامريكي يحذر من خطر
مسيرات ايران على الاستقرار العالمي
روسيا تمطر اغلب مدن اوكرانيا بهجمات
صاروخيه من البحر الاسود وتقصف خمسه عشره
بلده في بخموس
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]